Peter you couldn't you could probably
count on one hand how many companies
startups are out there in the country
right now that are focused on national
security in some form or fashion and
that have reached so-called unicorn
status meaning a billion dollar
valuation or greater I believe you've
funded all or nearly all of those
companies how do you think about this
well by my count the number is two if we
look at companies started since the end
of the Cold War last 30 years 1989 to
2019 they're SpaceX and Palantir and you
know I was cofounders of Palantir and I
was the first outside investor in in
space I've been heavily involved in in
both of those uh and I think there's
always over like a glass half full glass
half empty version the you know the
glass half full version is that I I
think innovation will get driven by a
lot of innovation gets driven by smaller
companies that get started and that's
scale over time and so this is
absolutely critical when not that many
people are doing it if you were one of
the few who does it there's a lot of
opportunity and then at the at the same
time we have to you know acknowledge
that in in the aftermath of the Cold War
there were sort of ways in which the
military sort of contracted into this
sort of a posture where all the funding
went to the major the major primes
and it became much harder for this sort
of small to mid-sized entrepreneurial
system system to build and and I think
you know as a venture capitalist you
don't want to invest in tiny consulting
companies that always stay tiny and the
you know where there's some some videos
and kradic use and it sort of goes into
you know a cool de stack that's a broom
closet in the Pentagon or something like
this you want to do things that scale
that get that get bigger over time and
and this has sort of been the you know
and I think there's there's there's
definitely a lot of there number of
times than made in in recent years in
the in the US military to to try to
correct for this uh for the sort of
procurement process but I still think we
have we have a ways to go
which begs the question I think you just
mentioned Palantir and SpaceX certainly
SpaceX is changed in the way that
Rockets are flown has it created or have
these companies created a template for
other startups to follow within the
space well there there's certainly that
there's certainly proof that it can be
done it in both cases took you know
wickedly long times probably close to a
decade to start getting significant
contracts from from from the US military
and and you know in in some ways they
were not conventionally venture fundable
you know I personally funded pound here
Elon personally funded SpaceX we got
outside capital maybe six six years in
to both both businesses and so if you
have something where you have a six year
gap and and can only get funded by by
someone who's putting in tens of
millions of dollars as a sort of
slightly quixotic project that's a
that's a tricky template to to repeat I
think you know I think there definitely
are lessons one can learn from Palantir
and SpaceX you know we made a lot of
mistakes there may be ways to to just
sort of develop these things more
quickly to procure things somewhat
faster but if you have a decade-long
process that's uh that's that's you know
we're supposed to have long time
horizons but the time arises are not
that long the one thing I will add that
I think is a tremendous testament to
both those companies and and a role and
others that are fast growing and now
have momentum is is the the people that
are attracted to high-growth really big
historic narratives and so if you think
about the flow of talent the flow of
human capital the flow of financial
capital you know they don't want to go
into these you know small hotdog stands
or these thirty million dollar
businesses but when you see people
voting with their feet and I in no way
mean to offend any of the Prime's who do
incredible work but many of the top
engineers are saying you know I don't
want to go to for example Lockheed which
is you know one of my investors they
want to go to some of these high-growth
early companies where they see the
opportunity to create you know fortune
in the future as much more attractive